dissensions luc ferrandez on a mis dans
l'esprit de la ville de longueuil en
tout cas un point final à une histoire
qui a pris des proportions incroyables
l'an dernier novembre dernier la vesle
annoncent qu'ils doivent abattre un
certain nombre de cerfs de virginie en a
trop dans le parc en train de détruire
le par il en a vu cette montée est ce
que l'udc commence avec vous elle prend
la bonne décision s'est appuyée par des
faits puis là doit pas reculer
oui je suis un j'en suis persuadé mais
c'est une mission qu'elle va devoir
prendre à répétition parce que les
chevreuils pour continuer de se
multiplier la sso et au doublé depuis
l'an passé on va râler ramenée à dix ou
quinze mois prochain quand lens moment
c'est justement la période de rut donc
novembre décembre ils vont continuer
d'augmenter mais oui elle a pris la
bonne décision et je suis content de
voir que la tête de conserver
concertation mentionne aussi les
bernaches j'ai visité des parcs ans en
suède où les parcs étaient inutilisables
départ quatre fois plus grand que le
parc lafontaine par exemple inutilisable
à cause de la présence des verts vaches
je comprends que souvent les humains
prennent la place des animaux avec les
valeurs l'agrandissement constat des
bonus mais il faut aussi garder des
parcs en ville et lorsque les animaux
prennent trop de classe b il faut aller
déplacer ou les abattre il y avait eu
années une montée levée de boucliers moi
je me suis je recevais des courriers
injurieux
j'avais osé dire ceci ou cela sur la
science en un il y en a trop ils mangent
les arbres ils mangent tous là c'est un
peu la victoire de la science contre
le côté irrationnel c'est ce qu'on aime
les animaux mais ça dépend dans quel
contexte heavy y venaient mais est ce
que c'est la bonne décision
je me pose encore des questions 121 d'un
équilibre dans le parc on parle du
parquet magané on parle là qu'à la
quantité qu'on a deux chevreuils de
longueuil on peut le dire comme ça les
serres lessard d'amérique mais ce qui se
passe là dans le c est ce que c'est ça
le problème des ddd chevreuil est ce que
est ce que c'est parce que aussi pendant
la pandémie les citoyens ont recommencé
à investir le parc davantage en prenant
des marches en sortant des sentiers en
allant aussi brisé la faune de la flore
il ya aussi beaucoup de nouvelles
attendu lundi devant train de me dire
que vous vous laisseriez croître vous
avez le droit non non je ne dis pas ça
mais je dis est ce que c'est la bonne
décision de juste dire on va tuer les
chevreuils ils vont revenir l'année
prochaine on va les retrouver parce que
ils vont continuer comment il va se
propager moi j'ai pris le temps de lire
cette semaine ce qui se passait ailleurs
rentrant j'ai regardé un peu tout ce qui
s'est passé l'année passée avec
sauvetage animal qui disait il ya des
solutions qui mérite peut-être d'avoir
d'avoir leur place c'est-à-dire les
stériliser de façon chimique on veut en
garder une quinzaine que les caisses que
soit le soin stérilisés il se
reproduiront de ceux qui veulent faire
pour être exact heures les dirigeants la
dizaine qu'il laisserait dans le parc ok
mais pour les autres on nous dit c'est
dangereux de les déplacer de les envoyer
ailleurs l'année passée le zou mineurs
qui étaient à saint félicien avait dit
nous on est prêt à les prendre et
lorsqu'on dit c'est sont les déplacent
ils vont être traumatisés puis
finalement ils vont tech mourir mais moi
j'aime mieux avoir une chance de vivre
que de me faire tout de suite sans cesse
et on peut continuer je me dis est-ce
qu'on est allé au bout des choses pour
avoir cet équilibre là et je trouve que
c'est une solution qui est peut-être
trop facile de dire ok on les tue c'est
réglé on n'en parle plus mais ça va
continuer puisque la flore et la flore
vol à l'afflux la faune et la flore vont
se régénérer par ce recul a saisi des
questions
d'abord moi je pense qu'à une différence
entre traiter les animaux de façon
humaine et les traiter comme des humains
c'est pas pareil
abattre un animal en prenant soin de
deux ans assurant qu'il ne souffre pas
en sachant qu'il y a des dizaines de
milliers de chevreuil qui sont abattus
par la chasse notamment ça ne semble son
prend toutes les précautions au delà de
ça me semble être une façon de traiter
de façon humaine vouloir les conserver à
tout prix
je m'interroge c'est la population de
chevreuils au québec n'est pas un n'est
pas menacée on parle de quelques
individus seulement j'ai personnellement
je trouve que c'est irrationnel le
les villes élimine des milliers des
dizaines de milliers d'euros par année
je sais que leurs os est beaucoup moins
bon qu'un chevreuil mais on les élimine
sans aucun aucun questionnement le
chevreuil c'est en tout cas c'est
extrêmement ku mais il ya toutes sortes
d'espèces animales en ce moment on est
en train de menacer de chevalier cuivré
dans le richelieu parce qu'on veut pas
réduire la vitesse des bateaux il faut
être cohérent si on a si on considère le
chevreuil le chevreuil comme une espèce
animale qui n'est pas en danger on a des
espèces animales qui sont en danger la
rainette faux grillon juste à côté le
chevreuil n'est pas en danger il faut
bien traité il faut bien le il faut bien
la battre la battre de façon la plus
humaine possible mais pour moi la
question se pose pas un livre est ce que
c'est parce que c'est un animal très
jolie copie comme ça vous fait douter
n'ont même pas mais moi je suis la
petite cousine de michel pageaud l'homme
qui parle aux loups en abitibi que celui
qui a fait un refuge avec des animaux
justement qui était blessé et que les
trappes à les ramener chez lui pour les
garder moi moi je fais partie de salaire
pas de l'ombre la boj thomas n'y a pas
de prédateurs lui déséquilibrée ya ces
titres et sa soeur s'est déséquilibré
dans le fou l'équilibré si on peut les
transporter ailleurs pour qu'ils
puissent continuer à vivre correctement
qu'on ne dise pas qu'ils vont être
dépaysé ils vont manger en touche la vie
ont peut-être vous l'avez fait mais je
vous invite à lire le rapport qui a été
donnée à la mairesse que je lequel on
lire hier ils ont quand même tourner pas
mal toutes les pierres puis le comité
puis avait plein de monde l'attendait il
ya en a pas d'autre façon c'est pas vrai
qu'on peut les diplômés très bien des
bonnes idées comme bravo sur les
policiers pourquoi je vous laisse aller
la mairesse a nous avait dit deux sens
de montréal
250 policiers de plus
lorsqu'on comprend est-ce qu'on n'avait
pas lu les petits caractères en bas luc
ses 250 politiques sont engagés mais
s'attire la mairesse avait été
c'est pas une question de déclaré la
mairesse avait été claire elle avait
parlé de 250 policiers de nouveaux
policiers de policiers supplémentaires
c'est elle a joué avec la vérité je peux
dire qu'elle a menti en ce moment c'est
l'étude des crédits budgétaires c'est à
dire qu on est en train de fabriquer le
budget qu'on va déposer un incessamment
et qui va être votée en janvier et c'est
très très très très cher d'engager 250
policiers de plus si on remplace 150
policiers à la retraite sans vent la
retraite par 150 nouveaux policiers ont
fait des économies parce que les gens
qui partent à la retraite quand même
plus d'argent que les nouveaux policiers
et là c'est évident on va engager une
centaine de plus on peut arriver en
engageant une centaine de plus avec le
mécanisme d'économie qu'on va faire
permettant un peu d'argent en plus mais
250 policiers en plus de remplacement
des 150 à la retraite c'est un coût
gigantesque et madame plantes
sous-estimer ce couleurs pendant la
campagne électorale
on aux jeunes gens en erreur par exane
touche tellement existe encore une
promesse qui n'est pas tenue dans son
premier 100 jours faut se rappeler la
dernière campagne où elle avait dit on
n'augmente pas les taxes et la première
chose que les fesses et augmenter les
taxes et les applis sur un autre nom et
l'a fait exactement la même chose la
limite maximale prévue par la loi de la
police de 4800 policiers ce que denis
cosnard avait dit avec son équipe c'est
que nous on va il disait nous on va
remplacer ceux qui partent à la retraite
mais on en rajoute 250 nouveaux
le besoin en plus ils l'avaient estimée
à 110 millions et madame plante est à
les aider nous on va faire la même chose
sauf que maintenant à ce dj en disant
non à voir remplacer ceux qui vont
partir à la retraite donc soixante et
cent soixante l'année prochaine donc on
va en avoir remplacé les 250 mais c'est
pas 250 nouveaux ça c'est 250 qui sont
là on a encore les lois de la police
permet d'avoir deux cent cinquante
nouveaux on parle de sécurité on
n'arrête pas de dire qu'on n'a pas assez
de policiers pour nos jeunes puis tout
ça et là on nous dit ben non c'est pas
ça que j'ai dit on en a parlé ici
parlent en notre planète ni appelé
mamilla les élus ni super mettre un
bémol moi je pense pas qu'ils manquent
de petit à montréal on en a plus qu'à
toronto toutes proportions gardées mais
oui mais ça n'enlève pas le fait que l
alu et les biais dit que la m'engagerai
250 de plus de six mois car là dessus
mais le froid pas ok promesses brisées
vous dit à peine quelques jours dix
jours maintenant 15 jours ci sa première
première c'était sa dernière promesse
mais c'est la première qu'elle enlève de
son de son call fait donc à vos pouvoir
dire un crochet mal le paf et puis
encore une fois lorsqu'on parle de
politique de cynisme non seulement
pourquoi il ya juste la population qui
était le jura merci le caniche prend 10
secondes avec vous pour dire qu' il ya
des gens d'autres médias je pense qu'ils
ont dit que des menaces de mort contre
la mairesse de longueuil concernant il
n'y a pas eu de management l'effet yo
prud'hommes il ya eu une menace sur
facebook jugée sérieuse elle doit
peut-être appeler la police demain mais
ça pas des menaces de mort ne comprenons
plus
repartir tout ça merci beaucoup parce
que l'ancienne mairesse avait déjà vu
des manades ce qui n'est sûrement vrai
merci beaucoup à vous de à bientôt